from our first lesson focusing on the
migration of indigenous people to the
land mass that today comprises the
united states we've made it all the way
to the present a journey in time of more
than 15 000 years we've looked most
closely at the last 500 years starting
with the arrival of europeans in the
americas now in this last unit we're
focused just on the last 40 years of
american history from 1980 until the
present
how can we examine something that's so
close to us in time we're still in this
era it doesn't have a name not like the
gilded age or the revolutionary era at
least not yet maybe this is the
post-cold war era or the post-9 11 era
maybe it will be defined by the changes
brought by technology and we'll call it
the information age trying to think
historically about the present gives us
a better understanding of what it was
like to live in the past to not know
what was coming next or how to interpret
all the complex threads of politics
society and culture weaving together
around you life is messy and confusing
we don't know if we're living in a
tragic era or a triumphant one neither
did the people who lived in 1940 or 1860
or 1770 so years from now when
historians write about the period from
1980 to 2020 in the united states what
will they say well let's pretend for a
few minutes that we are those historians
from the future maybe we're living on a
space station a few hundred years from
now enjoying a rack to geno by the
replicator and discussing the united
states at the turn of the 21st century
would we be discussing a golden age or a
dark period let's apply some of our
historical thinking skills to this era
and see if we can determine what effects
changes in this period had on american
national identity first let's talk about
america's role in the world in 1980 the
united states was still locked in a cold
war with the soviet union and when
ronald reagan took over as president he
moved the country away from the policy
of daetant or relaxation of tension kind
of live and let live with the soviets
that was pursued in the 1970s towards a
more active anti-communist stance
the end of the decade saw the collapse
of the soviet union so after more than
40 years of foreign policy that was
aimed at containing communism and the
influence of the soviet union capitalism
and democracy were now the dominant
economic and political systems and the
united states was the world's lone
superpower after the cold war ended it
wasn't immediately clear what the new
u.s role in the world should be should
it return to an isolationist stance like
it had before world war ii should it
serve as the world's police officer
keeping the peace and countering the
actions of hostile powers that might try
to arise during the 1990s the united
states had a few limited engagements
abroad in the gulf war the united states
defended kuwait from an iraqi invasion
and it sent troops to kosovo as part of
a nato peacekeeping force but the
terrorist attacks of september 11 2001
on the world trade center in new york
city and the pentagon in washington dc
began a new era of american foreign
policy u.s president george w bush
articulated what's been called the bush
doctrine which asserted that the united
states has the right to secure itself
against countries that harbor or give
aid to terrorist groups so under this
doctrine the united states went to war
with afghanistan in 2001 and iraq in
2003 after those countries refused to
surrender osama bin laden and the
terrorists responsible for september
11th the war in afghanistan became the
longest war in u.s history continuing
through 2019. at the end of this era
from 1980 to 2020 americans were
continuing to debate the proper u.s role
in the world should the united states
withdraw from wars abroad to save the
lives of american troops and the massive
budget expenditures of war or would
leaving the middle east further
destabilize the region and lead to even
bigger problems in the future some
questions that we might think about in
the broader scope of u.s history how
does the bush doctrine compare to
earlier presidential doctrines on
foreign policy like the nixon doctrine
the truman doctrine or even the monroe
doctrine and how does the war in
afghanistan compare to the united
states's second longest war the war in
vietnam the end of the cold war and the
rise of the war on terror weren't the
only major changes in this time period
there were also far-reaching social
changes how work was done
how much people were paid for it and who
did that work in the late 20th century
the emergence of the personal computer
and the internet made it possible to
communicate and to do business all over
the world in an instant at the same time
barriers to trade fell between countries
in 1994 the united states signed the
north american free trade agreement or
nafta
to reduce or eliminate tariffs on trade
goods between the united states mexico
and canada the growing international
interdependence of business and the
mixing of cultures that business carries
along with it is called globalization
but the availability of cheap goods and
cheap labor that globalization made
possible also had some economic
consequences for american workers
manufacturing generally moved overseas
to take advantage of lower wages and
regulations and union membership fell to
a record low meanwhile the share of
americans working in service oriented
jobs rose the largest employer in the
united states in 2019 was walmart wages
have stagnated for low and middle class
american workers while wages have soared
for the richest americans a study by the
federal reserve found that although the
total net worth of u.s households more
than quadrupled between 1989 and 2018
most of those gains were for the wealthy
with the top 10 of households
controlling 64
of overall wealth the top 1 percent
alone controlled 32
another social change of the late 20th
and early 21st century was the growth of
immigration the 1965 immigration act
ended national quotas in immigration
which had barred immigration from most
countries other than western europe as a
result immigration from latin america
asia and africa grew changing the racial
demographics of the united states some
of the biggest questions of american
politics at the end of this era concern
the effects of globalization and
immigration putting this in a broader
historical context we might ask how do
the developments in this time period
compare with say the second industrial
revolution in the gilded age when new
manufacturing technology opened up many
new factory jobs and lured many
immigrants to american cities but also
bred great inequality of wealth politics
in this period also differed sharply
from the era that came before it from
1932 to 1980 liberal ideas had dominated
american politics that government should
be active in securing the welfare of
people and that taxation should pay for
those initiatives but there was a
growing conservative movement starting
in the 1960s and ronald reagan's
election in 1980 began a period of
limiting government regulation and
lowering taxes and when democrat bill
clinton took office in 1993 he largely
adopted that same stance he declared
that the era of big government is over
and reduced welfare benefits
significantly the 1990s saw the
emergence of the culture wars battles
over the growing multiculturalism
secularism and cultural acceptance of
non-traditional marriage and family
relationships many conservative
christians feared that the traditional
american nuclear family with christian
heterosexual married parents was
disappearing meanwhile liberal
progressives celebrated the growing
acceptance of lgbtq citizens and
diversity in public life this was also a
time of bitter partisan divisions with
citizens not only more strongly
identifying with one party but
increasingly vilifying members of the
other party is immoral or unpatriotic to
put this in a broader historical context
we might ask did these partisan
divisions suggest that american national
identity was fractured beyond repair or
that a party realignment was underway
how does this period compare with the
1850s when the beliefs of the north and
south diverged sharply over the
institution of slavery ah these are very
difficult questions i'm glad we're here
in the 23rd century enjoying the
benefits of hindsight to assess that
strange period from 1980 to 2020